hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar an
introduction to immuno-oncology
at miltoni biotech i am michelle ashton
of labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by milton biotech
to learn more visit milpanebiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send your questions will be
answered by our speaker
after the broadcast via email you may
also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus
offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits
by clicking on the continuing education
credits window
i would like to now welcome our speaker
dr marcelo stein
the global product manager and group
leader
in immunology t-cells at miltoni biotech
marcello you may now begin your
presentation welcome everybody to an
introduction to immune oncology at
military biotech
in the next 30 minutes we will briefly
cover the basics of immune oncology
and what you can expect from us as a
biotech company in this field
this presentation will thereby also
function
as an introduction to our whole immune
oncology webinar series
here is an important disclaimer that
states that unless otherwise
specifically indicated
multi-biotic products and services are
for research
use only and not for therapeutic or
diagnostic use
please acknowledge thank you
as for the agenda we will have a short
general introduction to immune oncology
define the term more in detail
clarify how we as multiple biotech cover
this topic
and finally what solutions we can offer
to support your immuno oncology research
so let's begin with a brief presentation
of our company
milk in the biotech was founded at 1989
by stefan milton himself
and is the largest owner managed company
in germany
we have two main sites in germany one in
berger's gladbach
where the headquarters are located and
one in tetoro with our gmp manufacturing
facility
our products are sold in over a hundred
countries and we currently employ
around three thousand employees
worldwide
our mission is to serve the needs in
life science research and to translate
new scientific findings
into clinical applications so of course
immune oncology is one of the most
prominent fields we as a company are
active in
for more than 30 years miltoni biotech
empowers the advancement of biomedical
research
and enables discovery in cell and gene
therapy
however what is immune oncology
definitely a topic on the rise as covers
of well-known scientific magazines show
bristol maya's crypt very nicely
describes that
immune oncology seeks to activate the
body's natural immune response
to fight cancer indeed brief
and to the point this means that the
immune system interacts
with a tumor in several ways either
leading to an anti-tumor response
or birth to tumor evasion
effectors like t cells nk cells and
macrophages
are able to kill tumor cells under the
right circumstances
and elicit an anti-tumor response
the other hand suppressors like t-rex
mdscs may down-regulate set effectors
and even support tumor growth finally
the tumor itself might interact with the
effectors
for example by a checkpoint inhibition
and inhibit
their activities all these interactions
are points of leverage
to either attack or protect the tumor
immune oncology exactly addresses these
points
in order to modulate the equilibrium and
tip it over
in direction of an anti-tumor response
thereby
there are many different ways to target
cancer
besides the conventional approaches like
surgery
radio and chemotherapy immune therapies
are on the rise
researchers all over the world work on
the development of anti-cancer drugs
in the field of immune oncology such
drugs are for example tumor targeting
or immunomodulatory antibodies that act
on checkpoint inhibition
or act as stimulatory signals
furthermore
anti-cancer vaccines oncolytic virus
therapy
and adaptive transfer of gene-engineered
immune cells like t-cells
nk cells or other cells are applied
finally also cytokine infusion can be
exerted
to further modulate the immune system
to have all these approaches available
immune oncology has come a long way
defining moments and key players in
immune oncology research
as well as first steps in immunotherapy
go far
go as far back as 1891
pioneer william coley for example first
understood
that the immune system can fight cancer
and used bacteria to induce an
anti-tumor immune response
and after a series of immune oncology
milestones
we got finally our first fda approved
cartesian therapy
in 2017 however also the miltoni biotech
has its own immune oncology history and
milestones
since its founding back in 1989.
the game-changing potential of max
technology was not only immediately
adopted by pioneering researchers
but also led to new internal
developments finally culminating in the
foundation
of military biomedicine gmbh that is
fully dedicated
to new immunotherapeutic approaches and
all these milestones resulted in the
development of thousands
of therapeutical agents of whose
temperature is still in the research
stage
so there's still a lot of work ahead but
miltoni biotech will do its best
to support immune oncology all along the
way
for the past 30 years miltoni has built
a deep and active network in immune
oncology field
through our academic grid we have
partnered in many international and
national consortiums to build knowledge
and push immune oncology research so
we are part of a key learning societies
like aacr and ebmt
and organize events that gather experts
in the field
encouraging scientific exchange and
collaboration
for military biotech this means that you
can support the immuno oncology research
in different fields such as cellular
therapies like car t
cells therapeutic antibodies such as
checkpoint inhibitors drug discovery
for example in compound screening
new antigen vaccination when assessing
for example immunogenic peptides
and finally also other immunological
field
such as graft engineering in fact
working closely with basic researchers
clinical researchers and clinicians
we developed a fully translational
portfolio spanning from bench to bedside
and obtained a deep understanding of
immune oncology research
and commercial cell therapy requirements
well
there are several ways to categorize or
assess
our immune oncology portfolio one way
is to divide the different products into
the immune cell subtypes
they are meant for like t cells b
cells dendritic cells monocytes or nk
cells
another way is to arrange the product
into specific
immuno-oncology workflows following
thereby
an immuno quality experiment that
requires a specific set of product
solutions
that we can then pre-arrange and provide
for and finally our immune oncology
products can be grouped into their
respective
technology categories like cell
separation
cell culture or flow analysis so let's
have a closer look at the different ways
to assess
our immune oncology portfolio and i'm
sure you'll
easily find your best immune oncology
solution
as mentioned before we have dedicated
cell separation
cell culture and analysis products for
the most important immune cell types in
immune oncology research
nk cells t cells b cells dendritic cells
and other myolit cells
are all well covered with very specific
solutions
on our website www.miltonip
backslash immune oncology you'll find
dedicated chapters
containing all products suited for the
respective cell type
as well as extensive marketing material
ranging from brochures to protocols to
webinars
a more workflow oriented approach
groups our products into research fields
like for example car t
cells antigen specific t cells
therapeutic antibodies
or the tumor micro environment
in such workflows like depicted in the
lower right side for the cartesian
workflow
all product solutions that you need for
a respective field of immune oncology
interests and to successfully form a
given experiment are covered from start
to split
to finish reference data is of course
included
last but not least our immune oncology
products can be categorized
into their respective technologies
sample preparation cell separation
cell culture and cell analysis if
at a given step of your experiment a
respective instrument a reagent is
needed
for let's say cell separation or
the culture choose from our respective
technologies
to optimize your own workflow however
whatever way you choose to look at our
portfolio
and to categorize the products it will
be for sure helpful
to find your ideal immune oncology
solution the question is now
where do you get all this information to
find the optimal solutions for you
immune oncology research
well we have several info or contact
points for you to choose from
most importantly there's our immune
oncology website
with all the immune oncology cell type
and workflow categories
furthermore we have educative webinars
compiled
that cover immune oncology topics in
depth
and finally you can meet us personally
and talk
directly to us at congresses and
symposia
so well let's have a closer look at all
these information hubs
the main infohub of our immunocollege
activities
is our immuno oncology landing page
you can access it via
www.multnebiotech.com
backslash immune oncology please
check from time to time for news and
updates
there are two main link connections that
will bring you either to the different
immune oncology research interests
or to our immune oncology activities
in the upper row you will find the
immuno-oncology research field
as so-called application tiles
leading you to the different sections
such as car t-cells therapeutic
antibodies
tumor infiltrating leukocytes
anti-advance-specific t
cells or drug discovery in the lower row
however
you will find our immuno oncology
activities
such as congress and symposia the immuno
oncology innovation award
our ayamuna oncology webinar series and
the local immuno-oncology max days
talking about activities we are present
on all
major immune oncology relevant
congresses such as aacr
isaf aai and many more the upcoming ones
are for example simt aai mai
and we are happy to meet you there
another important activity
is our immune oncology innovation award
submit your conference abstract and
innovative research will be awarded with
travel
accommodation registration to selected
immuno oncology meetings
the next travel award will be given for
the dc 2020
the abstract submission deadline is
at august 26th of course
also in our immuno oncology webinar
series
is the most valuable source for immune
oncology specific content
older webinars can be listened to as
recordings
while for the newer ones you can attend
life
our immuno ecology webinars cover topics
like
therapeutic antibodies car t cells drug
discovery and the tumor microenvironment
upcoming next in may and september are
respectively
our latest solutions to improve car t
cell research
and therapeutic antibody research
discovery of functional essays and
finally military biotech encourages the
networking of immune oncology
and the cell therapy researchers around
the world with local meetings
such as the immuno oncology mux days
that you will find for sure also in your
area
upcoming next are the max nk day in
madrid
in june as well as the max io days in
beijing and paris
in june and july respectively well let's
now have a very brief look at some of
the immuno ecology topics that we will
cover
and the workflows that we provide
details can be found in the respective
application tiles on the immune oncology
landing page
and of course in our webinars for
example we cover the tumor
microenvironment
understanding the immune response within
the tumor is crucial to develop new
immunotherapy approaches
tumor infiltrating leukocytes such as t
cells
b cells and nk cells as well as myelin
cells
interact with the tumor in different
ways and may hold
the key to future immunotherapies
however the main challenge is here
that the target cells so-called tumor
infiltrating leukocytes are extremely
rare
and located in a difficult to process
and very
heterogenic environment the tumor tissue
so how to efficiently isolate and
analyze for example tumor
infiltrating t cells b cells nk cells or
myelin cells
our two microenvironment workflows allow
the efficient dissociation of tumor
material
and subsequent tumor infiltrating
leukocyte
isolation with maximal efficiency and
minimal cell loss
that way the target cells can be
analyzed in different ways
to for example facilitate a complete
multi-parameter
tumor immune phenotyping not only
involving
plastic flow analysis and sorting but
also imaging oriented analysis
looking at the spatial distribution of
tumor infiltrating leukocytes
within the tumor tissue either using
light sheet microscopy with the ultra
microscope 2
or imaging platforms such as the maxima
indeed the maxima imaging platform is
one of our highlights
that allows to stain tissue and cell
cultures with hundreds of fluorescent
antibodies
sequentially to allow assessment of the
spatial distribution of cells
in tissue structures for example
different
tumor infiltrating leukocytes in the
tumor micro environment
find more out about it in our recorded
webinar
isolation of tumor infiltrating
leukocytes
and optimized workflows for faster and
improved analysis
presented by dr cesar evaristo another
important topic
is the generation of therapeutic
antibodies
antibodies can target tumor antigens
or curtiline pro tumor regenic factors
and function in different ways first
they can trigger the immune system to
attack and kill the cancer cell
second they can block the growth signals
third they can prevent the formation of
new blood vessels
in more detail therapeutic antibodies
can either block or activate receptor
signaling
and can thereby even induce programmed
cell death
or block tumor growth by binding for
instant gross factor receptors
moreover they can neutralize or block
protumorogenic factors
to inhibit tumor growth engineered
antibodies
conjugated to radioisotopes or
chemotherapeutic
drugs can target tumor cells directly
and
kill them antibodies can also be used to
activate the complement cascade
of the immune system leading to cell
lysis
or complement dependent cytotoxicity
also abbreviated cdc finally
the tumor-specific antibody can be used
to attract effector cells via the fc
part
defector cells then actively kill the
tumor cells
this approach includes in k-cell
mediated antibody dependent cellular
cytotoxicity
also called adcc macrophage
mediated antibody dependent cellular
phagocytosis
also called adcp and finally
t-cell dependent cellular cytotoxicity
abbreviated tdcc
here is an example for a workflow our
customer could use
for the generation of therapeutic
antibodies and the products they
might need first we have sample
preparation for solid tumors
the tumor dissociation kit can be used
to get a single cell suspension to
isolate target b
cells however some working human samples
might work with blood products a
starting material instead of tissue
here sample preparation is not required
and strides from pbmc b-cell separation
kits
and microbeads are used after the b cell
separation with the respective beads or
kids
the b cells will be analyzed using our
affinity flow antibodies
and the mux quant cytometers b cells can
then be cultured for expansion
human b cells can be expanded using the
b-cell expansion kit
or other means however also for mouse b
cells many different cultural reagents
are available
finally those b cells can be used for
screenings and sequencing
to be able to finally transiently
express the monoclonal antibodies
and test them for their functionality
indeed
for the generation of therapeutic
antibodies they involve b-cell culture
can be quite challenging
for this reason we developed a b-cell
expansion kit
including recombinant cd40 ligands a
cross-linking antibody
and il-4 this allows efficient expansion
of b cells in vitro
anti-expanded b cells display an
activated phenotype
with a similar distribution of memory
and plasma cells
as in the original effect fraction the
kit is a standardized and reproducible
system
that can be used in future for clinical
processes requiring gp standards
however other options such as more
cytokines or
trl legions are also available
and as you can see the b cells nicely
expanded up to 10 fold and upregulated
activation markers such as cd86
and mhc class 2 occurring again
you can find out more in our recorded
webinar
all you need for your immuno oncology b
cell research
presented by dr susana beetke
our last example for today is the car t
cell research workflow
so what are car t cells cartier cells
are genetically modified t
cells that express a chemeric antigen
receptor
abbreviated car specific for a given
cell surface antigen
for example a tumor antigen and are
therefore able to kill their target
cells
for example cancer cells to manufacture
them
either for research purposes or in a
clinical manufacturing environment
usually donor or patient blood is
collected
then the t cells are separated
and genetically modified to express a
car with a given specificity
the modified t cells are then cultured
and expanded
to receive a relevant high number of car
t cells
and finally either analyzed in a
research context or infused as
so-called living drug into a patient
where they can then kill for example the
target cells with our car
t cell research workflow we provide
product solutions
for every step of the car diesel
workflow that allows the generation of
car t cells in a research context
from t cell separation to car
transduction
to culture and expansion of the car t
cells and finally the phenotypical and
functional analysis
and thanks to the max gmp product line
and the clinimax prodigy
the described small-scale car t cell
research workflow
can be straightforward and seamlessly
translated into a clinical manufacturing
settings
and all this is of course also backed up
by functional workflow data
cd4 plus and cd8 plus t cells were
isolated either from pbmc
here labeled with cycle plus mb
or directly from a buffy code here
labeled with
the abbreviation sf for our straight
from product line
using max technology isolated cells
showed highest purity and the
physiological cd4 to cd8 ratio
cells were then activated transduced and
expanded using our extensive t-cell
culture portfolio
analysis of activation marker
expressions such as cd25 and cd69
showed a very efficient activation and
transduction efficiency analysis showed
also highest transduction rates finally
cells were tested for functionality not
only by surface marker analysis and
cytokine release
but also for the real killing capacity
in summary
isolation transduction and culture of t
such as max technology
leads to fully functional car t cells in
small scale
as well as in the clinical manufacturing
context again
find out more in our recorded webinar
improve your car t-cell research
presented by
dr zasker rush as a bonus i'd like to
point out
the great hands-on training offered by
max academy
you can register for a training of
interest on the max academy website
www.multnebiotech.com
slash resources max academy slash
hands-on training
amongst the many options also i o
relevant trainings are available
such as clean max productivity
car t cell analysis and of course many
many more
with that i end this presentation i
would like to thank you for your
attention
thank you marcelo for your informative
presentation
we would also like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor milton biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions submitted today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labviews will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
event until next time goodbye